you can't say it wasn't me especially
with the Milton moustache was me but you
got a milk moustache bro
hi I'm sting and I'm Shaggy and we are
here to give you some life advice shut
up
sure timing I need an epic icebreaker to
ask the girl I fancy on a date drew from
ah you must be tired
cuz you've been running around my mind
all day that's pretty good
did that work this is Lexi from Bromley
my girlfriend caught me red-handed
creeping with a girl next door what
should I do why she isn't answering my
calls anymore it's sad it's tragic
actually
I've go round with some flowers where
that will cost you money Wow I've lost
it this is from Rebecca from Ireland
that's interesting so here we go
one of my housemates keeps stealing all
the food and milk from the fridge
how should I investigate this crime well
I think you have to confront him or her
look this is a partnership you know you
can't have all the food in the fridge we
have to share it and he can't say it
wasn't me especially with the moustache
wasn't me but you got a milk moustache
bro I might as good bro how are we
that's why it's the odd couple
[Laughter]
[Music]